-Our first guest tonight
is a very funny
Emmy-winning
writer and comedian.
She executive produced
the docuseries,
"Visible: Out on Television,
which is streaming
on Apple TV+.
Here's my conversation
with Wanda Sykes.
Wanda, it's so good
to see you again.
-Oh, good to see you too, Seth
-We're obviously living throug
some difficult times right now
but are you drawing any help
from the protest movement
that we've seen
in this last month?
-I am. I am.
You know, they look
a lot different now.
You know?
They are very diverse.
We have a lot of young peopl
out there, which is great.
And it feels different.
It really does.
And they're --
it keeps going, you know?
And it gets bigger,
it's growing.
So, I am --
I'm hopeful.
-When this first started,
hopefully, I heard this right,
that your instinct
was not to go to march,
but then you were sort of
overcome by this movement,
and you and your wife
and your kids went out?
-Yeah.
Yeah, it was that night
that I had some --
I had a few tequilas,
and, you know, and it was just
one thing after the other.
And, you know, I just --
I just lost it.
And I just had to talk
to some people
and went on Instagram
and went live.
But, um...
Yeah, and I meant what I said.
I was like, you know, I'm not --
I'm not doing it.
It's not our problem.
We keep doing the same thing
We keep marching,
and nothing changes.
So, you know, we're the victim
of the problem.
It's your problem.
You have to fix your problem
And when I, you know,
saw the marches
and how many people are ou
and the response and all
from, you know -- from
the George Floyd execution
it gave me hope, you know?
Especially when I saw, also,
religious leaders
speaking out, too.
That was like, "Okay. Now folk
are getting it," you know?
It felt like people
were getting it.
-How did your children
like being at the march?
-Well, they loved
the marching part.
But then, once the stationar
part happened, and, you know
we're listening
to all the speakers,
then they were bored silly
-[ Laughs ]
-They were --
They just wanted to go home.
They were hot.
And I think -- I'm pretty sure
my daughter faked a heat stroke.
I'm pretty sure.
-[ Laughs ]
It was just like,
"Ah! Ah! Ah!"
I'm like, "Okay.
That's good.
That's a good one.
That's good," so...
-[ Laughs ]
In your fantastic last special
"Not Normal,"
you talk about the fact
that your wife is white,
your children are white.
How has it been in this moment
talking to them?
Because I would imagine
children have a curiosity
as to why people are so upset.
-Oh, man.
You know -- [ Chuckles ]
It's been difficult, because
you know, I have to tune it out.
I have to turn it off sometimes,
because there's always something
that will just make me go nuts
I just -- I just --
I just get so angry and hurt
And, actually, I talked to som
of my black friends about it
especially my sorority sisters
They, all their kids are older
and everything now,
so they've been through it
So, I'm like,
"Look, I'm having issues.
I'm trying to talk to my son
about the George Floyd case,
and he's like, 'Uh-huh.'"
And I said,
"So, the police officer,
he had his knee on his neck.
And my son's like,
"Yeah, that's bad.
He killed him."
I said, "Yeah."
And he goes,
"He should go to jail."
I was like,
"Yeah, Lucas, you get it."
And he goes, "Um, so what'
your favorite dinosaur?"
I'm like, "What? What?"
-[ Laughs ]
You know, that's kids --
"I got it. Let's move on.
Next topic," you know?
So...
[ Both laugh ]
So, I have to just let the
be kids, you know?
It's like, you can't --
And that's what
my friends were saying.
It's like, "Look, let them
enjoy their innocence,
and let them be kids.
You're raising good kids.
They'll get it," so...
I don't want my kids
to later in life, you know
someone ask them,
"So, what was your mom like?
and they're like, "Whoa,
that was one angry bitch.
Let me tell you."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Ooh, she was mad.
Hoo!"
-Well, my next question
was gonna be
what your favorite dinosaur is
but now I feel like
I should skip it.
[ Both laugh ]
Wait. If Lucas ever finds out,
tell him to text me.